oh a hundred percent man i don't
understand it because he's he's like
become such a stronger character down to
one safe now uh the the clash dash one
but so many things but here we go guys
we're gonna be going to arguably the
smallest uh stage in the game the suk uh
the saudi arabia stage let's go man
here we go versus brian and i know that
we'll know that match up really well
execution let's go
starting it off
all right he fell asleep at the wheel
now he's moving here we go starting off
the match up here let's see what he does
starts the jab fighting back oh i like
that he went for some cheeky cheeky hell
sweep stuff there
nice he tried to punish there oh with
the 1-1-2
should be able to get the wall oh he
misses the one two though
oh no oh no
punish eight
[Applause]
that is a
declaration of
okay let's do you got to be careful
the bomb mix-ups are going to be great
he could have done down three two but
doesn't matter hey
two rounds straight round three it's bag
you all right you good
fight i'm loving it but i'm enjoying
this
tangent upper do it
i want to see it go for some of your
skill baby
i think you can do that nice
nice he's trying to adjust he's
sidestepping he wants the right
positioning here
oh boy when god oh nice slow and then
while setting 2-1 guaranteed after that
or
when god on the scoreboard now two
rounds to one
lovely there you go nice bill put his
own suppression nice side step
good break wow
okay i'm lacking this pressure i'm
loving the pressure
pressure
the pressure of snake head
again
this guy's a bad oh no launcher
[Music]
beautiful fundamental play there getting
the first match versus wind god one note
beautiful
beautiful brian play
oh yeah
i like i particularly like the you know
the snake edge uh finish the combo go in
for the snake edge setup i mean he
stayed on the ground but if he got up he
would have been done if he got up he
would have been yeah i'm just saying and
then what we saw then he dashed up and
did the the qc back four you know the
soccer kick and then he caught him
because he was ducking because he was
scared to get hit by the snake edge
that's mind game that is mind game 101
guys you guys can learn something from
this so make sure you watch uh very
closely because bella is the lcq
champion of tekken world tour he's a
very very strong player and he's showing
you guys how to play prime good stuff uh
win guard down one or what do you think
he's gonna do here he's gonna maybe go
to another character
um i don't know see again because of the
unfamiliar uh unfamiliarity with wind
god um
maybe he's to try to fight fire with
fire
maybe he's going to pick his own snake
edge i don't know
yeah oh yeah right
even and up right right right right
yeah we saw the kuni mitsu come out from
lovely and we saw aslan even use uh the
puny mitsubis this seemed to be a quite
popular choice for people who wanted to
play in these in these conditions so
yeah i mean uh let's see what he does
here but i i mean we didn't see many
hell sweeps we saw a lot of mid options
from um from wind god against uh bilal
bilal wasn't ducking a lot he did
challenge a couple of the lows but maybe
if anything let's hear that adaptation
go for the lows a bit more man bring out
the ru kang you know the uh the seven
health sweeps in a row sometimes you
just gotta do it to him
yeah i mean gotta keep him on just let
him know you're not afraid to do it
right
yeah and one other one other strategy
which i think is really good is i call
it the sneak edge it's not snake edge
it's sneak edge right you go for the
torn
and then you cancel the taunt into a
snake it's just called sneak edge guys
is below gonna be able to sneak edge
either way oh the leroy my god
this uh
the first leroy or the day that we're
seeing on stream but i think this is a
strong choice leroy
based on the conditions that we have
sometimes you just going into it blind
and leroy is doing just that let's see
what he does how he's able to get into
this matchup the presence of not just
the perry but also just a lot of his
moves that are able to kind of interrupt
the flow of what bilal's trying to do
here and look at that he is
oh gosh he drops it though
hey he's trying to parry
bro you can't do it
what's wrong leroy you can't see the
snakes
yeah that was that was a punish against
the the parry as you can see that he
baited out the parry he knew that he was
gonna go for it and he went for a
snakehead punish that was beautiful
stuff from below
oh he might be dead oh my god he could
have backboard him to
kingdom come yeah what's going to happen
here
nice double knee
he's trying to hit him with the forward
too be careful by the wall
oh no
no way
[Music]
round ender moves that brian has is if
you want to be safe go for that
oh nice
these day catches are working so well
they haven't been blocked even once what
is happening
trying to go for the sawed-off shotgun
here i like he's trying to be a bit more
compact he went for the back one plus
two then going for the the cane
yeah the grab
he has another opportunity you can get
greedy and go forget he went for the low
again
nice overhaul the mix-up beautiful
ladies and gents below we'll be moving
into the winners finals here for toc
south asia beautiful stuff there mixing
up the snakehead with the upward four
beautiful beautiful play wind god is not
out of the tournament yet he will be in
the loser bracket still alive but man
below the